Ben Folds here on the Rich Eisen show
and sitting right to my right the man
himself good to see you Ben Folds thanks
man thanks for a pleasure I am a huge
fan of your work and it is remarkable to
me and understandable because of your
remarkable talent you listen to music
for eight hours a day at age 2 yeah you
remember this yeah I remember how old
are you now Ben 53 so that was 51 years
ago if my math is correct
so you remember something as a 2 year
old that's a fact absolutely absolutely
we lived in about 14 houses when I was a
kid that was one of them when I was 2 to
3 years old and I can show you the floor
plan of the house in my head I know
where everything was and I confirm that
to my parents I think it probably is
because I was listening to so much music
I didn't know it was eight hours I
called my mother when I was writing the
book and said what do you think two or
three hours and she's like eight which
got me a free trip to the child
psychology so we're what were you
listening to everything that was
available my parents would just
basically throw records on the floor to
me and I'm like like a little Richard a
whole lot a little Richard okay some
Elvis I didn't like as much and then
Kitty records you know like I'm little
teapot short and stout okay so you got
so a little bit every little bit of that
what was the most influence for you Ben
definitely a little Richard that was
just a wild abandon and the piano
playing is just was in my bones from two
years old that's that right yeah okay
and so when did you first set and to sit
in front of a piano the first well we
got a piano when I was nine years old my
father's construction worker he got a
piano for pay for a gig that he did
where I don't know they couldn't pay the
whole thing they gave him a piano right
that's when I first got full-time in a
piano and then it was all the time as
soon as that landed in our hallway then
it was already blocked in the hallway
without me like sure to the middle of it
and I played all the time so what does
it mean that one of the first records I
remember as a kid was Alan Schurman oh
yeah who used to sing you know hello
mother hello father
Here I am
yeah I had this single about a little 45
out of 44 45 I had was Mack the Knife
yeah is listen to Bob Bobby Darin Glen
Campbell's Rhinestone Cowboy
I played the crap out of on a 45 on my
record player in my room what a great
saying I but I was like six or seven I
could not remember a thing about being a
two-year-old
yeah well I'm eating one of the things I
put in in in in in the book at the
beginning not as a thesis for the whole
for the entire book but write that that
I listened to so much music is very
compelling to someone who is a music in
the brain neurologist person who studies
these things will tell you that the
associative you know properties of
remembering music brings back all these
other things that's why these them and
dementia dementia patients and and and
and stroke victims sure you know because
your whole brain lights up over music so
you can find all kinds of ways to get to
information from there and I do believe
that the reason I can remember so much
from Tears old is assume that I did I
remember what the memories of memories I
mean I I'd hurt my arm on a radiator
burned it and I don't remember the
actual event but I can remember
remembering the event I can remember
looking at my arm where had the scar Ben
Folds here on the Rich Eisen show did
you ever try sports
did that ever oh I loved oh I loved a
soccer loved soccer when I was a kid I
was a terrible hack a tennis player
because I never had any lesson so I I
would always just have to hit a forearm
or vary a foot forehand or or or or like
a one-handed kind if I wasn't a very
good player what else I like I like
boxing when I was a little kid we all
had boxing gloves like these massive
16-ounce boxing gloves and we I mean
you're from North Carolina doesn't that
require you to have at least some form
of basketball game or anything like that
Oh basketball was big to I'll you know i
remember basketball for just being
miserable having to go play it because i
just got the ball stuffed in my face all
the time and the whole time I'm thinking
I would just reassure myself that right
I'm a good musician
I can do this like like you just to kind
of try to keep some confidence because I
just got smeared in that right word so
you told me backstage you had a cup of
coffee at Duke is that a that's a true
story you were there for what how long
were you at Duke I was a semester I was
a semester to basically help with their
they they didn't have they do in abroad
program right and they needed someone to
teach percussion so I was given a
scholarship to go along and teach
percussion and technically was there
took a couple classes over there before
in the summer did you go to any hoops
games and inside Cameron interview you
weren't one of those face painters or
anything like that that waited out for
15 hours to say that you saw Carolina vs
Duke no I was pretty pretty and pretty
invisible there I lived in lived in
Chapel Hill for a few years so you know
but I never went to the football mask
you know we met before at the US Open
yeah you performed on the US Open late
night show that CBS did for three years
that I was honored to host for three
years do you remember did you go to see
any of the tennis would you show up and
play your songs and get out of Dodge no
we we went straight to the airport from
there yeah no kidding yeah because it
was right down the street from LaGuardia
that's right yeah okay right there at
the u.s. Tennison that's right and oddly
enough this is right on the way that to
LAX I will only see each other on your
way to the airport it seems that way oh
that's amazing
why is your book called a dream about
lightning bugs Ben Folds well it comes
from a dream when I was 2 years old and
the dream was was chasing lightning bugs
being the kid who could see them while
the other kids couldn't unless I pointed
them out put them in a jar made kids
happy I remember as an adult this dream
because it strikes me it's a really good
metaphor for what an artist does which
is you see something as it flickers yeah
it's only for a moment you try to
capture for other people everyone sees
different things maybe the other kids in
the in the dream might have seen stars
in the sky or clouds rolling in I'm not
saying like I'm the only one to see
sinks it's just an artist is responsible
for that which he or see she sees the
other thing I like about is that
lightning bugs
fireflies disappear into the light of
day and to me that's a good metaphor for
applying intellect or take
make crafts to the inspiration as soon
as you start thinking about it it wants
to disappear into the light of day and
but you have to anyway because that's
part of the art well it's it's it's a
beautiful notion and metaphor as you
point out and one of the many reasons
why my wife and I wanted to send our
kids to summer camp on the East Coast up
in Northeast they didn't they don't know
what a firefly is or a lightning bug out
here in Southern California it's kind of
crazy for people who grew up on the East
Coast in Santa Monica for a while and I
would just look for bugs on the ground
they'd like there was none of no bugs
I missed bugs while oh is there any I
know it's kind of an interesting
dichotomy in that respect what's your
most personal song that you've put put
out there Ben
no I don't know I mean I think an
obvious example would have been a brick
which was a big hit but many of many of
my songs have really personal either
interest or experiences inside them but
then I'm allowed to turn them into
something broader fictional if I need to
yeah but but I think I'm willing to put
anything personal into a song if it
makes it a better song and so often it
does because you actually feel as the
writer I don't have a particular
discomfort in doing that because I kind
of look at it more like a lab technician
right who's trying trying to build the
best song I can and if it's pure fiction
and I got to be like David Bowie and go
to Mars to write the song awesome
what is landed about that's truly that's
the one that leaps out to me landed was
about a good friend of mine who I felt
his experience a lot in what I saw
happening I played it for him once once
we recorded it and he goes that doesn't
resemble me at all and a couple years
later realized that it resembled me more
than him which i think is an interesting
thing about writing is it very often you
you see someone who you relate to and
you write about them only to find out
later it's more about yourself
interesting you know what landed is
coming up and the other side out of a
relationship which which distanced you
from everyone else and everyone's
probably done one or two of those
where your girlfriend or boyfriend
causes a bubble for the two of you and
you don't relate to your old friends
anymore or your family Ben Folds here on
the Rich Eisen show how in the world did
you wind up collaborating with William
Shatner walk me through this Ben when I
was a kid and I should have put this in
the book you know but when I was a kid I
was a huge fan of the album transferred
transformed man and I bought that it at
a yard sale on the damn thing it's worth
so much now I have a copy myself you've
got a vinyl copy damn straight I do when
did you did he I knew we you know we
were birds of a feather in a way here
it's a beautiful album I know it's funny
but the thing is is is there something
so compelling about his voice it's so
out of bounds it's like off the chain
well he was doing beatnik versions in a
way right of Rocket Man and and coupling
them with Shakespeare or coupling them
with Sarah no I mean he was he was being
he was it was interestingly you know
especially put together so you you were
not a fan of Star Trek but rather his
mutant Star Trek all the kids love Star
Trek okay but I love this album and when
I was 8 16 years old yes I wrote a song
for for Shatner I wrote one that I
wanted to hear him speak and I went to
the library and I looked up the William
Morris Agency in the library and I sent
the song to him and I got a form letter
back mr. Shatner blah blah thanks you
and all that kind of stuff yes and years
later when I knew the fix was in that we
were gonna have a hit song I was like
okay one of them my childhood dreams
here is I want Shatner to speak my song
so I was able to make that happen he was
on the way to the session and I realized
oh man this is a song written by 16 year
olds is terrible yes so I rewrote the
whole thing before he got mine come on I
did I rewrote the whole thing before he
showed up we performed it and this was
1997 we became really good friends been
buds ever since and so it was naturally
we'd make a record together his record
label wanted him to make a silly record
of covers like you know Madonna and
stuff like that just to be ironic and
funny that's a bill I think you need to
tell your story until
the truth and he did and it's a
beautiful record in love right is the
name of it is that in love is the is the
song that I wrote that he spoke and the
the album that we did together as his
Alba cult has been was in 2004 and you
know we got Joe Jackson in for that got
had this crazy moment where we also
almost pulled off having Bill Clinton
play sax Weezer be the be the the band
and a gospel choir in him all doing it
live which would been crazy but we had
to wait so long for Weezer that we ended
up losing Clinton Holder saying Weezer
was the was the missing piece is the
most difficult piece to put together
from absolutely Bill Clinton was a big
Star Trek fan so I said to a shatter
just just call Clinton we've got his
address and stuff in Harlem you can call
me cuz really the president I was like
yeah yeah call him he's probably a fan
and he called me back like 20 minutes
later like penny I spoke to the
president and he said yeah and
apparently a Clinton sing was like yeah
I'm happy to do it
just like sure ban does let me sound
like and that was that was his and then
his book came out the problem was his
Clinton's book came out and he was on a
book tour so as soon as we zur said yeah
maybe we can do it we had lost it so the
way it turned out was actually really
good we had a Joe Jackson smeared it and
was fantastic that Ben Folds Iran the
Rich Eisen show a couple minutes left
with the author of a dream about
lightning bugs let's play a little bit
of celebrity true or false with Ben
Folds before we head out on down the
road
you know our previous drop used to have
Spandau Ballet at the very end of it
correct right what's your celebrity true
or false very good I like it
um but you didn't have the Spandau
Ballet part of it yeah we what's your
favorite Yacht rock band if you could
name one Yacht rock band Ben Folds
letter dis log in some machine account
of course I liked log intimacy and that
might be Priya
well there's seals including leave
there's Daren okay I'm just seals like
oh yeah yeah that that um summer breeze
summer breeze it's good I mean I mean I
have a soft spot for that stuff that's
just that's you know that's Christmas
criss cross Christopher Cross we've all
been caught between the moon and New
York City Ben you understand we've all
been there is the first one for Ben
Folds the celebrity true or false you
were taken to a child psychologist who
told your mom that you should be held
back in school she didn't thinking that
you were just creative is that a true
story that's true okay and it all worked
out for you in the very very long run it
seems to have I feel pretty normal
okay very good you had a scholarship
full scholarship playing drums at the
University of Miami and you had to play
your final exam with a broken hand you
broke in a fight the previous night is
that a true story that's correct but it
should be understood that I hit the wall
and not the guy you hit the wall yeah
yeah the guy come to beat my roommate up
I was sort of standing in to take up for
him for some weird reason it's just a
southern thing and I don't know what I
was thinking the guy was on a wrestling
scholarship and he was an amateur boxer
and he killed me and and and and I had
to be dropped off in a police car from
the hospital for my final exams and my
hand was broken my nose and my stitches
everywhere was it was terribly
embarrassing is it true you had a how do
you like me now a moment where you
performed in 2005 and the Dean gave you
your scholarship back is that true
we didn't do any kind of scholarship II
thing but no so that's half that's half
true okay I did play with their
Orchestra and got to talk to the kids
about the story I'm one of my proudest
sort of achievements oddly is that I
threw my drumset in the
after after losing my scholarship at the
University of Miami and the ears later
it's one of the first things that a
freshman music student finds out is that
they talk about the legend of my drums
in the lake and I just that fills me
with such essential sense of
accomplishment would you ever want to
bring it up like the Titanic like
literally find it and bring it up
something you know I mean there's been
jokes about we could make a like a scuba
diving you know expedition documentary
well I mean you might find the hardware
but certainly the wood would have been
would have would have rotted but they
could probably find something how real
was a movie whiplash I think whiplash
was was very real I think like any kind
of entertainment sometimes it's good to
exaggerate it so it feels there but I
would say whiplash there are old-school
jazz guys still teaching that are rough
as they say in Australia rough is guts
uh-huh and they they are close to
abusive because that's the way they
learn music they care deeply but they
are rough last one for you right here
first official gig Ben Folds you played
polkas at a German restaurant in North
Carolina and they required you to dress
the part with lederhosen true or false
that is correct that's true sir yep Wow
is there a photograph of this summer oh
yeah it's in the boys photograph yeah
wouldn't you there's so many pictures
you're just gonna miss some of them okay
I was I was I was a that guy tried to
carjack me got in my car when I had my
little later hose and on and like
midnight at a gas station and that's in
the book too because it just I pulled
out a knife because my father had a
knife in the in the car and asked the
guy to get out of my car and I looked
down him like my little legs are hanging
out of later hose and wooden clogs and
stuff and I'm in a Bronco or a suburban
it sounds like Judge Reinhold and in
fast times it was that embarrassing Long
John Silver outfit yes I love that scene
where he's throwing it's throwing it all
up and real quick you you know you saw
our Caddyshack poster in this room and
you have a story involving that too I
just looked up that clip where dude gets
hit by lightning with because my son
just took a great interest in golf and
he's getting very good at he's 20 years
old
and the other day he was out in North
Carolina he was out on the green is that
what you call it sir yeah and apparently
he got an indirect lightning hit Oh my
golf cart
I guess the rubber tires are a very good
thing yes but he tasted metal he he lost
feeling in his toe crazy so you
responded by sending him a clip from
[Laughter]
fantastic follow him on Twitter at Ben
Folds on instagram at merck & pianist
reckon pianist but you know what I don't
I can't get in anymore you've been
locked out I've been locked out and they
won't they won't help me out so so
forget my Instagram well how about this
we'll help just by throwing that out
there hopefully we'll get your Instagram
account unlocked and then you can get
William Shatner here to come on the show
and do the Eagles fight song fly eagles
fly for us we're trying to get him to do
that it'll move you to tears I bet it
would I'd love to hear it in the room I
bet it even more beautiful I dream about
lightning bugs check it out right now
we're all books are sold Ben Folds you
are awesome thanks for coming man thanks
for having of course anytime that's Ben
Folds he's now heading to the airport
that's the way we roll we chat I
introduced him on a talk show of mine
and then he's off to the airport that's
what's going on right Hatter
very good that's Ben Folds right here on
the Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel - 39
on DirecTV for free on be our live or
download the Rich Eisen show app